Okay, that's me up. Hi reflings. Hi snowberries
Hi everybody
They become together
Snowlings
Hi
Reese Berries, I think that would be the combine
Look who I brought with me. I hope I say
You can open up her POV by clicking
The link so you need to see both of her POVs. So if
We we woke up yet. We're awake. Mm-hmm. We're totally 100% awake. We're gonna play the tutorial
I woke up late and then I was like, thank God I see streams at this time because I'm not streaming at this time
I'm too shattered. I'm exhausted
Yeah, but we're gonna play the tutorial together for the first time now
Have played this game many moons ago, but it's been a very long time and AC hasn't played this game
So we're just gonna add I'm stupid. No
I don't know how we're gonna escape the room neither dad, but it's snowberries
You guys give me a heart attack
Responding to AC's tweet by the way because one of you is you know who you are
Said to her don't forget to take your
Mmm, I don't know if I can say it like that
But they were like don't forget to take your very specific type of pills that she's got named
I don't know if you guys know what reference in
But I was like AC why did someone just at me with don't forget to take your tarred pills
Bees look like she's like oh
But yeah, I had to explain to her that that's what the math are actually called like literally
They're like I see started at no
No
Right, I'm gonna click play fingers crossed that okay nothing goes wrong or explodes. Oh boy. Okay. Let's see
Don't look
Okay
Break your PC. I'm so sorry
Okay, okay, look at this guy's similar your simulation will begin shortly. Okay
SD or arrows, okay
Nice baby music, I know if you can drag larger objects right on the chair, okay
Okay in the same room with I've been in me when I'm mad
Oh
The game in church was flying
I'm taking out a square a triangle in a circle. Oh, I'm putting in my inventory. Oh good. I'm not gonna remember that
Opening the closet, okay
Oh
Yeah, let me know if you can hear everything, okay
Look at me doing baby puzzles, let's go. Maybe I can do the soft or all maybe I can
There's hope
There's a shortcut for collecting items for the get 10 balls
What happened to the music? Um, what the fuck?
To the music
Your music died, why can't I hear anything? Hello, you hear me music?
Yeah, I don't know what happened. I couldn't hear anything
Oh
Just randomly I couldn't hear anything
Yeah, we're so good at this game. They had to nerf us. Yeah. Oh my god. Okay, pick up the puzzle box
Okay
Protect the box
Okay, I try the clothes to
Okay
Oh, I pinged
Strani pinged. I don't know what that means. I don't know how much either literally I'm an about I'm really playing basketball
Any pingers? Okay
Why oh, I'm playing basketball. Oh or not. Never mind. I'm having a loading screen
Oh my god, oh my god, you dressed up as well
Blake, she's in her jewelry. Oh my god. That's so cute. I got my little reflund on my head. I don't know
I saw
I can't show the reflunds. You need to go open up. Oh nice. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Check the fit. Check the fit. That's right. Sorry
All right, so um, we're in a baby room definitely
This is my room. Let's fucking go
We're done mom
I'm mom from the break house
Oh my god, it's emis rats. Oh my god. It is emis squeakers. Oh my god
This rat's getting a spanking. Get on the bed right now. Why?
Did you
Get emi pch a streak
And now she can't stream for a week
What literally if you guys didn't know very quickly emi bezu is not allowed to stream upload or do anything for an entire week
Because her rat sniffed her 3d o microphone. Am I telling the truth?
Please open up twitter right now and look at her
Thing because yes, it's really ridiculous. It's absolutely ridiculous
Um emis rats were too sexy. They literally gave youtube a bone bone
What's that? What the I can't find one thing. We're actually supposed to do I'm gonna be honest same
I have a picture of like
A lamp
Oh, look two four seven look okay, okay, okay two
I'll do it in this one as well. Just in case. Oh, I know I can't be that one
Seven okay, let's see gating late
Okay, mysterious toy. Oh, there's another piece
The puzzle piece that I can put in this thing
Oh, sorry, I'm sorry. Oh, sorry. Sorry. I just stream sniped her. I just stream sniped her. I'm so sorry
I say I literally just stream sniped that. Oh my god. Oh my god. I don't know if I lost the piece
Did it not go in?
I don't know if I lost the
The puzzle piece. Oh, no, we're not wait. Oh, no, it's so over. Wait if it no, no, no
It must have went on is in your inventory scroll with your mouse wheel to check out your inventory
Uh, I don't have anything. Oh, there's another one
Oh, you see if you find any baby manual things we go on this little board here
Oh with now we just need two more
One two more puzzle pieces
That doesn't look like a puzzle at all. I've done it
Yeah, okay
I'll investigate this plant to the best of my ability
I love how cute this room is
The game's actually a really cute one overall
All right
I'm trying my best to find like
The other puzzle pieces right now. That's what I'm focusing on. We need a cord. It's
It's got a badge and a plus sign. I don't know if that means anything
Have you found what?
The this like lock here has like a badge and a plus sign on top of it. I don't know if that means anything
I really need to stop picking puzzle games for collab games now that I think about it. This is getting out of reach
Okay
Okay, I thought maybe there's a puzzle piece in there, but I guess not
A ball
I hope you find your way home always yours. Una. Who's Una?
I have no idea
It's not part of your puzzle, but it's a part of something. All right
Do you I'm going to put it on the table
But if you have an inclination of where the heck this piece goes, that's so random
Which piece that the tape misty. It says mysterious key, but it doesn't look like it fits on anything
Oh
I guess I put it here for now
Can I do anything with the cat? Let me see
Is there anything hidden?
Is it a little hole? The plan is sus. Is it? And I'll interrogate it. I don't think I won't
Everything looks like distortion, but it can't be
I
Token found you found a secret trick and look around to find more you found it
I did not find it. I found a secret token, but I don't know
I don't know what it's on the ship
It means does that take a look at your legs by accident?
Okay
Oh
Is there anything in here you got pinged again better not
Anything in you can bend stuff in the dress
Bro, I'm so sorry, but we're actually stuck on the tutorial level
Look, I found another puzzle. Oh, oh, is it the last one? Oh, no, there's one more. No, no, no, no
No
One more I need one more
Wait, wait, hold on zero seven
It says a badge, but there's no such thing
Viller in puzzles the literal enemy, bro
Oh
Where's do you have the cage?
Uh, I think it's back outside
I brought it in
On the bed but it's gone. Oh, where'd you find the cage? It was just on the bird's nest. I guess it's not there
Wait, can we go back in the trash?
I don't know it says it's empty. Oh, I have it. I have it. Okay. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait
Let me see
Uh, oh, I see it. Whatever it is. Can you touch it? Let me grab it
I was trying to figure out the control but we're stuck at the tutorial
I can't open it or nothing press spacebar when it's in your inventory
You should be able to interact with it
Yeah, I'm trying to interact with it, but like
Oh, okay, okay
Oh, I uh, oh, no, it's fine. I got the right thing. I'll put it around. There you go. Esteban. I bet you it was you Esteban
I bet you it was you
Oh, Esteban has a thing in his ear
I just find the secret look in what was in the birth key. I don't I don't think that does anything
Huh, I thought I thought maybe putting in the birth
birth
In the birth cage would do something
What's this mysterious key nothing in this room looks like it needs a key like that
There's a hint button beside the door. Oh, is there actually why am I pinging? What the hell is this thing?
There's no right. Okay. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. Can I push the hint button or do you want no hints?
Give hints. There was never a tutorial. I'm too embarrassed
Oh, what's the hint? Are you joking?
It's literally just a picture of the chest and nothing else. Yeah, we know the chest is locked. You don't need to tell us
That's it. Wow. Thanks for nothing. Literally give us another one
Right. Okay. So the hint is a police badge and the plus thing
This on the map
Five go to the police station to the hospital. Hold on a minute. Wait five
Five six four
But the block is
Bruh
What nine five six four. Fuck it. I'm guessing I'm guessing nine. Oh, sorry. You were just
Tell me about you. You do it. You do it. Wait. I'll say nine five six four
And before it's not it's not that damn what the heck bro, you need to give us a better hint than that. I'm not kidding
What zero at the end then
Okay, it's five six four zero or something like that or zero. I wonder
I can't believe five six four zero
I didn't oh, I don't know. Why did you I didn't even do that, right? But we
Yay, we did it. Yay
Mummy there's blocks
Oh, we did it. We're out. Oh my god. We did the tutorial. Let's go
Oh my god, we did the freaking tutorial. Oh my god
Really? My god camera. That's kind of scary. Look at us dancing. That's you in my head. Look at that
Oh my god, you're biggie. You should be in there
This oh my god
I can't believe we actually escaped the room
I thought we're gonna be stuck here for two hours. Oh my god, you're breaking this. Wait, you can move
All right. Yeah, oops. No, no, don't worry. All right. We're gonna go to egypt. You've been to egypt before
No
So and now we're gonna be stuck there forever. We're gonna die like we're gonna die
Oh god, why is there a timer? I'm never gonna be able to swim again
There's a timer. Literally. What the heck? I think we're about to get like encased in tomb in sand here
Are we? I don't know. Uh, I think I'm gonna be there. Okay. Okay. Okay. I'm opening something. Oh, oh
Something inside
Okay, I will give me the thing. Hello tools. There's something inside the flask, but I can't take it out
Really click on it or
Like
Oh my god
Oh my god, I'm cleaning so hard right now. Oh, I'm such a woman
Oh, you're right. See there's the thing inside but like I can yeah, it keeps like
Moving wait, what the heck stay still. Yeah, we'll let me click it because it keeps bouncing off
You get put in the corner of shit
Is there anything else that can stand it? Uh
Is that wood? Oh look found something
Inside the vase
I don't know what that is, but I assume we will need it
Because there's like there's another piece. Look, there's two pieces of these
Oh
Oh, you did it ac
Wait, what did I do in the middle here?
Oh
Now what oh
They're together
We put the sphinx back on
No, we don't we don't
I wonder how to use the shower
I'm investigating
I'm uh, I need to look at the boot. Oh you found something. Oh
I wonder what the numbers are
Wait, I need to actually translate a book
Egyptian alphabet, is this real?
Oh
I wonder if like you need to like translate this thing. Oh, no
Wait, is there a book in that suitcase? Oh wait, I've got a freaking suitcase
Right, hold on. Give me that book
Give me that I need to start putting stuff down when I'm not using it because I'm not letting you investigate if I'm holding it in my inventory
How do I put that down? It's okay place
Oh
So what this I'm really oh here we go right. Okay. Okay
Can I write?
Oh my god, wait, I'm simple. Oh, right. This code is for the dominoes here, but from the boot. Right. What is it?
A girly skirt
One thousand
Okay
I'm supposed to put those numbers together without a piece of paper. Oh my gosh. Wait, so there's three thousand
Oh
My god, this is I'm I think I'm over complicated in this because
Is this
I'm just like picking up random items and I don't know what the fuck to do with it. Oh, you did it
Oh, you got an achievement. I got destroyed with an inventory for breaking it. Yeah, I'm doing like
Fucking nothing. Let's go. Oh my god. Wait, so this spiral is a hundred
I like the most useless. Do you make me happy like a game like this?
Let mom let mommy do all the work while
Fucking doing nothing
Egyptian higher verse system of numerals was represented by various everyday objects
I didn't realize we were going to actually learn in this game
I just wanted to play a cute puzzle game with my daughters. That's so much to ask like what the heck
Why am I looking at numbers?
History, right
Individual symbols are stacked together or form numbers their value is
Their values added as you can see in the following example one two three and four
Combine the same symbol when using more than one kind of symbol
It's 2 a.m. Please put it to rest count each symbol and multiply it with its value
to summon
Or reflins one a years are gonna have to just give us the code. What is 2 a.m. I'm not
What
What does that even mean so three and then like so that means 10
A dash is a one
Fuck what
What three thousand and um six and ten and whatever
It's so over it literally is
I open something here. I don't know what the fuck. Is there anything inside there?
I don't see anything. I also can't oh
Oh
vernaculars
Did you put it there?
Yeah
It's because you said it's you're like, oh, there's nothing there and I'm like, okay, I'll put some on there
Right reflins. Oh my god, right. Thank you. Someone just let us cheat. Thank you. I'm so sorry. There was absolutely no way in heck
I was getting that I would be up to ac
Unless you want to take a crack at it. So here you go. What is it? I'll put it right there. There you go
You take a crack. Let me see. I'll I'll just invest the game
Oh
Jesus
Um
Forming numbers
Individual symbols are stacked to get up to form numbers
Okay
Um
That's why I cheated that's why I asked the reflins. Um
You definitely keep opening the book and look
Um
So we have
Uh
We have
Uh-huh
The
Three
Yes, yes, we have three thousand. Oh my god. No way you're doing it
You're great
Yeah, then we have
Uh
The
How many spiral ones like did we spiral ones for hypnosis?
Well, there's two at the bottom and then yes, we tally them together and two at the top
So there is
I don't know how to count four
Oh my god, that's so good. Okay, and I think you're actually gonna do this
I was like what I thought you left the call and I was like
Is the I'm I wish you can't count I'm done
No
um
and then
And then we have 10
And and then we have like the others two spirals, which is another 200
and then 10 and then
So 3400 and then there's two horseshoe ones
so that's two
And then it it ends it ends with
2000 like the
symbol that looks like a lady in a dress
That's a thousand. Yeah, so there's 3000 see how you tally up the thousands because there's three of the lady in a dress
And then me explaining that as if I didn't get the answer
Because I was too dumb to figure out myself. Um, and then there's four spirals
Which goes in the hundreds column and then in the tens column. There's two horseshoes
And then in the individual column, there's
I don't
Oh
You actually did it on ironically though
You actually did it because I didn't get it
I mean, you're the one who calculated everything like I don't know what the actual numbers
To be honest with you. All right, so you did the calculating. I don't know what the fuck I was doing, but
Uh, okay something to put a key in
I'm going to put this key back here
I might be able to do
You actually
genius
Oh, it's what I think you're just because like you actually calculated all that's like
I do not I did not know like what the actual numbers are
Wait, oh, oh, what did we open? Oh, the new girls got me
Oh, it's a pyramid. Oh, we're making a pyramid to get the room
I see. Okay. So there's an extra pyramid part
And then there's so much coins. What do we do with them?
I have no fucking clue. Like what is the point?
What am I supposed to do with these coins? Hello? Wait, so do I offer them?
Oh
Well, actually, what do we do with this random dark? Oh
I just shove that in there. Oh
Wait, wait, I made it golden. Why? What the heck?
Oh, we can dig in this game
Why it says it's a key
I don't look like one
This thing says a key if there's no puzzle symbol, but say the name of an item is because it's not part of the puzzle
Speedrunning. Okay speedrunning. We're about to get the record
I don't know about that like I literally don't know what the fuck to do
Uh, how do we use the shovel?
It's apparently not part of the game if it has a
Key next to its name, then it's a part of it, but if it doesn't so then
We unlock all these coins for what? We put them in the water
Oh, wait, this is probably gonna
I just found it there
Right, we're washing the coins to offer why not
Okay
We literally have like two minutes left. We're fucking dying. We're we're gonna die
Wait, how did you find that hidden panel? Did you just touch the wall and it opened up? Is there more hidden panels?
Uh, I don't see anymore. Like that was like a sign of like a hand or something like that and that's
What I collect
Is there two minutes in this audio? We're bro, we got stuck on the tutorial like it is so hard for no reason
Okay, give me nothing
So I feel like we're just wait what the waves mean the waves don't even mean anything
Is that put it back that put it in the water? No
I don't think putting it in the water. Oh goodness. Why does he need a bath? Who or what did what did that do?
Oh
Why did we have to give him a bath off his mistake it worked. Oh, okay
Okay
Not me losing my fucking frames
Are you? Oh, no
Oh great more fucking puzzles wait, why aren't these easy? I thought this game was like accessible
What even is this
We're literally about to die like how much time do we have? No
Both of us low turn into the timer being like, yeah, we have a time. Um, oh my god
The bird right wait, okay, we enter the maze
And we touch a lion
Uh house a square and a cactus on the wheel. What the heck?
A lion
Uh a house. Oh
Nothing happened the timer is up, but like we're
Fine, it's for an achievement. I thought it meant you died. Oh, okay. That was actually rather easy. Okay. We'll figure that one out
Sorry, what do we do? Oh, is that the
No
Another one
A what
How do you do these
Wait, do we have to start with a particular one? Is it not telling us what to start? Maybe maybe the bird maybe start
Can you start with the bird?
I don't see a bird in the map
Wait, it's maybe it's the only ones that can reach the center
Uh
Okay, the beetle can't reach the center
The wasp can
I'm supposed to read that bird. Oh my god
Oh
I just come open and your legs are spread behind me. I'm like, uh, oh
Can I help you?
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing. I nearly died. This game was a mistake. I'm so sorry
I keep I'm like, oh these puzzle games. They look so easy and accessible and then we go play them
And it's like asking for so much like oh my god. It's
It's too much. We can't even do that. Oh wait, look
I have I have cheat. Oh my god. Yes. I love cheat
That's the only thing I'm good for for clicking on the cheat button
It's the the base wink wink the base. Here you go
So then what does that change? Uh
What's the change right? I need this foot clearly the eye
Is an eye
Wow, the beetle is a beetle. Wow. The bee is a bee
Oh, wow
That means water that symbol in front of this thing meant water by the way. I just figured out because I opened this book
Okay, okay
darkness water
Uh
It's so boring even
Why are we trying to write?
Okay, I think we have the book I get I trust you. Yeah, what even is this?
What are we even like trying to do in this puzzle? I'm just looking through the symbols and looking for the best
I
Be old and can't like what with that symbol even gain us
I don't
I'm pressing the button
The bee can make it. Yeah, I know the bee can make it. But what is that?
What is that? What do we do with the bee making it?
A different symbol the thing I'm trying to understand like what are these three
Like what are we trying to achieve? I don't know. This is the worst part
Like I don't understand
What were the bees?
What?
Right
So
The eye and the next one to the eye
One
What are you knowing about eye king and bee
Can all make it. Okay. So eye king and bee can make it. I understand that eye
I know
in a bumblebee
I don't know
Oh
And eye a king and a bee right understand. We'll have a nice day
Eye
Oh
A bee oh wait, so a pot of water a feather. Hold on right a feather leave that one
I
Feel so boring dad like I legit
I think
What I still don't get only be able to get
I
I'm sorry. I'll never make a click a game that requires puzzles again. Fuck it. Just give us the answer
Right. I get it. I get the bee, but I don't get it at the same time. You're gonna have to work with me
Okay, a bee is a leg a long leg
Okay, a bee a thingy. So then what I just found the middle one until we get it, right?
Oh
Just give me the answers. Okay, and then the snake the snake on G
Okay, uh-huh, and then what just rotate this last one. Hey
There we go
Yo, we are so smart. Let's fucking go. Exactly. Yes. Let's fucking go
It's a puzzle game and they just ask for that
Let's fucking go
lemon squeezy
I got this game
Too much this is too much, right
I'll force us to play one more than after that. I think I'm satisfied that we're good. Okay
Yes. Oh my god chamber of the dead run the same map
Oh
Like I didn't suffer enough
This scrolls are part of the puzzle the round stones are part of the puzzle. Oh my god
Oh
Okay, how do we have
I should get easy
What
How do you what that?
Shit me
Can't you can't you tell how bad?
What are we trying to achieve? Okay, let me let me I'll let you I'll let you go
So oh god, you just move the beetle about and you're to like highly tall is it working or doesn't it back? Oh, there you go
I
Yeah, you see like
I mean it's not bad honestly
Come on me. Let me restart it
I'm like so intently watching right now
I'm like miss my some like
Ah, yeah, it's like ah, yeah, I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
Oh, okay
Have we been trolled is this like an impossible puzzle how did you get into the same answer?
Uh
I
Feel like is this a troll puzzle and it can't be done and we're like wasting our time on it
Imagine another ring like
He says it needs to be lit up it may oh
I'll go explore the room a bit more
Apparently we're not supposed to do what we think we're trying to do
What do you mean, but that's supposed to do this puzzle then and we're not supposed to light up
We're supposed to make an image of something. I don't know what
Ha, bro. We would I'm not gonna lie. We probably would mean oh
Image of what these acu these wait wait wait wait wait wait
These big things up up here in their hands
Oh
Wait, that's so difficult to mimic
So the top left how the fuck am I gonna remember that shit the top left square in a backwards l basically not connecting
Oh
Wait, they're both the same. Oh, no, they're both the same symbols. So you only have to do it once. Okay. That's not
Whoa, that was so quick. Oh my god
Hard
Oh, can I break it? Uh, don't break my heart
Oh, I have a baboon head. Oh, do we put them in the middle of the
Uh, maybe not there, but we are collect the numbs. That's the main thing
Okay, okay. Uh, this is correct. Where's that?
Oh, you can't jump in this game. This is ruffling game use
Um
An eagle a snake in a wiggly worm
Eagle snake and wiggly worm. Oh
We need to count how many like the jar is
Uh
I really that doesn't break every time I'm moving something
Oh, there's like, uh
Uh
What is it called? There's like a compass. Yeah compass, that's right. Yeah, and it's showing towards north
What does he have in his hand?
I have symbols upon these mummification jars as I understand they represent four sons of horus
Me um the horse lands of horse. Yeah, basically
Uh, the lungs regarded by happy the baboon headed god representing north
Okay, north. Okay the jack headed god representing east
This is stomach
The head the human headed god representing south guarded for liver and lastly the intestines regarded by
The falcon in the west. Okay, so
Oh
Where is uh, where's the heart?
It's in that red jar on the floor
Oh, it's a weight puzzle. Oh, I like weight puzzles. Hold on a minute. Oh, hold on a minute. Just put my fat ass
Oh my god, I'm real
Okay, so the wiggly worm
is
No, head five is heavier than the wiggly. Oh, look
Oh, he wants some I don't know what he wants. Maybe put your butt cheek on where his hand is
That's called a piece the egyptian gods. I'll put there is a note on the floor. I'll put it in front of me. Okay
Oh
Oh, okay, that's equal. So this is worth two and then we take this one
Put it back. Oh
Snake is heavier
Look, I I was able to give him the thing
What did you give him the heart thing? Oh, and his hand moved lower
But he I guess he needs another thing. Which is this we have the baboon head. Oh, no, he doesn't want to
What is the thing like the second thing here? Does he want this?
You want a crowbar?
Nope, hold on. Oh
So it has to be four
Okay, it's worth four because
By a process of elimination
I have three fours and then we just need the bird
That bowl is heavier than two but heavier than three heavier than eight
Man none of these haven't
They break them
Oh my god, okay, I actually enjoyed that puzzle sorry about that. I said what I said I enjoyed that puzzle
Jack headed lived. I'm just cleaning the trash. That's that's all I'm doing
Oh, no
Right, so we have the oh wait, we have all the heads. Where do we put them?
I'm not sure
On top of the jars. Oh idiot. Oh my god. Oh, that's what the note is. Where's that note?
It's that something about the north
And
If you've got that note, we'll know what these are
North
You have the note. Oh wait, sorry. It's still on the floor. Hold on. I get it. Okay. The lungs are north. Hold on right
Okay
Okay, I'm starting to get this one is starting to click the stomach is on the east
Which is here
Oh, no, no, it's not
That was a brain or something. Okay that one goes there
And then open it up
and then
The stomach is on the south. Okay, right and then we just need to put the heads on the thing
The baboon we know the baboon head is north
The baboon head is north. Okay
And then where's the birdie?
The jackal headed east
And then
Human head god is south
Where's the other one? Oh, uh, yeah, so then yeah the falcon on that one
This yes, so we just need
one
More head somewhere
Did he you know he already gave it something
Uh, what does he think we touched the symbol? I don't know
The sarcophagus they say feathers
Do you have a crow? Oh, I have a crow
And say this sarcophagus, okay a beetle
And there's a lion lion
Then a lion and a beetle. Oh my god strani completed tomb raider
Oh my god
Are you are you still playing that game? Did you manage to finish it?
I I didn't finish. Oh, I know you didn't finish. Oh
No, I I think I'm I think I'm just gonna drop. Oh
Oh god, I'm a lot of talent
I can't believe king toot and came and drink food. Oh, we got a few favor
Oh
We're now if you
We're
Oh, I could give it to him. Oh, that'll be what he wants. Oh, yeah
Oh, wait, why is someone so much faster than the freaking tutorial?
That was so fast
Okay, we actually did this one. I don't did we dare for another that went so quickly compared to other ones? Let's try. Let's
Okay, let's try. Let's see. This one was more
That was great doable. Yeah, that was pretty easy and obvious whereas the other ones were like
Good luck and finding what you need and it's like, uh, okay. Thanks. I guess like
Yeah
Could you figure it out?
Right, right. Let's let's hope this isn't gonna be a repeat of the tutorial. We're gonna be dead drag
Okay, what's in the chest?
Oh
No, all right. Okay. Hold on. Let's just first analyze the the location. We need to use her. Oh
Uh, the anubis
Can you see this lever? Can you put it on like this? Oh
How could you do that so quickly?
I broke it. I wonder if that's the key
No, it's not
That's the key. Hmm. That's not can you pull this lever all the way down and hold it?
Which one this one just hold on. We don't just keep yeah
We're doing it. Oh my god. Wait, why is that?
Like, okay, we're just not we're doing so good
Oh, maybe we need to melt this
Oh
Maybe
Maybe some of these
I
Okay, but as much as you're like, oh, I'm only smashing things it actually helps because things come out of the stuff
I'm having the time of my life just smashing everything in this room. That's what I'm good
Oh
Okay, you put the key in that smell and lava thing
Yeah, yeah, we have four more things we need to put in it a cup a ram head anubis and an eagle that's on this piece of paper
So we're learning
A large pyramid we need it for something weird
That's all right. Oh, there's three dots inside the large pyramid. Oh, I think we're doing it. We've got one two three four five six seven
Just to confirm one two three four five six seven. We got seven in the wee one
See if the game was like this and super obvious, maybe we wouldn't have struggled so much
One two three four five six wait fuck on open the chest
Oh my god, yes, we're already done another one right i'm putting the ram head into
Nice
The chest is locked
Give him some beans the fair was the beans
I love how pretty this looks
The yeah, the game's like so that's why I was like oh we'll play because it's so cute. It's like a cute looking game
Hmm beans
What is the radio for
Are you under a rim?
No, that's a radio. I'm trying to figure out
What to do snowberries had too much candy. Yes
I mean that's that was just a token there was nothing else in there
I'm looking how do we open this? I don't know what that is. I don't know what this is yet
BAM BAM BAM
Like that's the head
Wow more boys
Oh, there's symbols on the front dumb ass
Dumb ass there's symbols on the front of this chest, right? Okay
Uh
The foot in the owl go to okay. Hold on the open house in a bird
Okay, and then next is a bowl and a lion
And then on this side it's a foot in an owl
Okay, another thing we got to you
Oh
Oh the thing we need to melt. Yes. Yes. That's three now. That's three
A gem
Oh, there's the baby. There's three gems. Hold on. There's three red gems. There's five
A pig and then two blue ones and then that's that one. Oh my god, we're speaking
Let's go
Is that is it one more item?
Whatever in this trip right had to open this one. I thought we put all of them
I think there's one more
How do I open this chest? Oh, I don't know. Oh wait. Wait this key movie gets used in it as well
Oh
What? Oh, no, it doesn't oh right. I thought I was gonna let me use the same key twice
These are came out. I wish literally this one's a tutorial harder than
Um, but we've interacted with everything on the walls and stuff
Why don't we do with this pyramids that was the puzzle for how much how many blobs were inside the thing
Uh
Um, I'm I think I can't figure out what we need to do to open this chest. There's nothing on it
Um
As you go in same and then hit in the hint button as well turn it around with the sheet. What do we need there?
There's a compartment underneath
What that was the key underneath? What? Oh my god
Oh my god
Wait, what that's done. Oh shit. Oh my god. It's just calm. Oh
It's gonna be like behold the gold is flowing into the lands of Egypt. I say look at the calm
Oh my god, wait, why is it getting so much easier? What's going on?
Everything is easier. Meanwhile, I can't do like
And you do like all of them. Okay. I won't I won't make you play anymore. I won't make you play anymore. Um
That
Honestly, that was an all right game
I didn't I have to admit when you can't even figure out what you need to do. It's like bra
Help us please
But like that would I don't know if some of it's starting to visually get a lot easier
Did they like purposefully?
I don't know. I see getting princess carried and it was my pleasure. I see
Real the princess carry is my pleasure. Um
Under the chest would have taken forever if we didn't use the hint
Honestly, I would not spot that. I'm not even kidding. I was like we've interacted with everything on the wall and stuff. So
Yeah, um, I
I'm gonna thank you. I see for collabing with me. Um, I am gonna do a wee bit more of zatsu
Um
On my own to complain about this game, but thank you so much for having me. I seen snowberries. That was lovely
We got there in the end. We got there in the end
Him right. I will jump out the call and then I'll disconnect the little vtuber thing, but thank you so so much
I love you. I'll talk to you later. Okay. Bye
I
That's favorite thing is when you end a collab and they're just sitting in the
Hold on hold on
That honestly that honestly, oh shit everything and it all just fades too
Okay, I know this isn't my usual steam stream time
But we did it. We actually did it. That wasn't that horrific that could have been worse that could have been
A heck of a lot worse. I'm not even kidding
But I enjoyed that. I started to click at the end there. Um, I don't know if I used to enjoy that
I'm like, I need to stop picking puzzle games. Let's stop picking puzzle games. It's absolutely killing my gen mates
Um next time choose another a different type no more puzzle
Literally, I forced Azur to do a puzzle game with me. I forced Marisa to do a puzzle game with me
And then I do what I say. I'm like brah
I need to start. I need to switch things up
Because I've got Emmy and she be on the way soon tm
And the game I had picked out for she be is a freaking puzzle game
um
Because she be was like, oh, I've never played um portal 2 and I'm like, you've never played portal 2
Please play portal 2 with me. I love it
Uh
You don't like puzzles on your gen makes like puzzles. Why do you keep doing this? I actually don't mind puzzle games. I just suck
Um, but yeah, apparently portal 2 is fun to oh, she was like, I've not played I'm like
What do you mean you've not played portal 2?
Like what would you mean and I'm like brah oops all puzzles
Literally, I'm like, well might as well keep up the streak now because if I'm gonna do a puzzle
I might as well do a puzzle with Emmy
Um, okay portal 2 is different. That's a fun path that your gen mates do need more stimulation in their brain
Bruh, I'm not even kidding. I got added onto it. So
I see tweeted that she's streaming with me
and then a freaking um
A snow very fucking ass and goes don't forget to set your target, but I'm like I say oh, what does this mean?
Hmm
Watch looking forward to you playing the witness
Wait, you've never no I've played portal 2 she be told me she's never played portal 2 and I'm like brah get me on it
Let me be your first
um
So I'm gonna message her
And see if she's um, okay. The only problem is
um
Portal 2 and 1 sit and takes five hours. There is no
Way I can ask she be to sit with me for five hours
So it may be two hours the first stream and then two hours the next one like two and a half
Mummy teaching her daughters how to play puzzles one at a time
I mean kind of because I'm familiar with all the games I've picked
It's just been a very long time. So I've forgotten everything
Um
The witness gave me a headache. Oh, no, I don't want to give because it would be in me that would play the witness
Surely there's
Being her first in portal 2 bags am her first
bags am her first
The portal to multiplayer does have some test level segments. So it's not
One long thing. Yeah, the witness is a solo game. Oh, you want me to play a solo
Puzzle game now hold on a minute
That's getting a bit outrageous with these these behaviors. That's outrageous. You can't do that. You can't do this to me
Literally green goblin. You can't do this to me expect to me to play a puzzle game on my own
And you don't give me any just any club is just play Minecraft
I think we're actually gonna get a Minecraft server at one point
Originally it was supposed to be this month, but as always things get delayed and there's plans and the works and that I'm
Like that. Um, I have a fantastic announcement for clippers. I finally did it yesterday
I wrote out the terms and conditions if you want to be a veiler
Established clipper. Um, and we're gonna see what happens if people apply or not or
If we go to bed, I'm so sorry. I'm not normally awake right now. I'm right now. I am
Gimli is um currently well
Normally when I sleep for gimli is like a heat seeking missile, okay?
And I am warmest at my crotch
So gimli is attached to my crotch whenever I lie down
Um, like cats are just heat seeking missiles. Honestly
um
I twitch a lot so vego doesn't like to sleep next to me. Um
Nah, strawney a Hongshuo
ah
I'm not like a
Um, my mum my mum used to say I was quite a freaky super in terms of like
ah
I'm like a jiggle about a lot and I grained my teeth in my sleep apparently
Like I should probably get like one of them plastic protectors to sleep with I had them somewhere but I lost them
Gimli just like me for real for real attached to the the hip
um
Attached to the groin honestly
I request to treat places with gimli immediately vealers
Those are I don't know who the sleepyhead of ealers. I think obviously if I go
Yeah, I woke up at 2 a.m. For this collab literally no one's gonna be like. Oh my god
strawney
You know like Dennis said I grained in my sleep. I needed that
I'm
Wait, do you mean grained as in like the night if I like you grained work, you know what one you're done two
You're done. Okay, strawney. No lie. My parents once described me as breakdowns into my sleep
My gran I had a sleepover with my gran and I woke up and I was like
Uh, like I shared the bed with her in that and I woke up and I was like
I'm shattered. I don't feel like I slept at all and she she turns around you. She's like strawney
You literally woke up like a demon in the middle of your sleep like you she said
Apparently I sat up and like in the middle of my sleep at like 2 a.m. The morning possessed
um
And my eyes were wide open and then I've I've fell back asleep again type thing. Um, so yeah, um
If if you're wanting to sleep with me reflin, just be warned. Apparently I do a lot of freaky stuff. So
You know, just be careful
There I might do something freaky with you
No, my mum's always made a comment about how I sleep as well. So
I'll most just be up your bow
I'll look at marshmallow
First marshmallow. Mummy. I gave myself blue balls. Okay. Maybe we don't read marshmallows. Maybe we read them another time
I actually thought about what I wanted to do from my first bandsly stream
Um, and it's absolutely deplorable
But I want to play the coffin of andy and lay lay
And enjoy it and it's full glory
Aim and what happens happens
That was my first one
Aim, that's my first idea
I don't I'm not gonna promise that anything happens afterwards
But all I'm gonna say is that's my number one. I'm like I'm like a hundred percent sure that's my number one
Aim interest
Okay, so I wanted to play it and then we can all comedically
afterwards
um
We go for the only
There's only one ending as far as I'm aware in that game
Then and oh my god, acy showed me this commission. She's been teasing a commission to the snowberries on twitter
and
She showed me the update and oh my god snowberries are in for a treat. She's so good at picking out that stuff
um
Uh, sorry
Yeah, if you didn't know what the big massive update is emmy got a freaking stripe because her rat sniffed
a
Um
Um rim rimmy. Oh my god. No, there's no rimming at all going on. I assure you. Sorry, right
I'm gonna stop looking at discord for it because this is what happens when emmy's rat
okay, um
emmy's rat came on the mic. It was probably estaban
in
and
Sniffed in the mic and youtube was like banable. That's that's popcorn
um, and I'm like
No, so we're asking youtube to undo it because she is like she can't interact with the account for a week
Like can't do anything can't submit this can't get the strike removed can't stream can't upload videos
Can't do a thing on youtube and that's literally her income source and I'm like
You need to relax, okay two rats were on the mic
spitting down the beat
She made that joke before her signature move would be a rim job. What wait, why did she come up with that?
What happened? What about me missing?
Came on the mic. It came on the mic. It went on the mic
Oh, do you not use sentences like that? Honestly, it's a little bit. Seriously, youtube has to fix their thoughts
Bro, I literally if you go on twitter and see the ridiculousness
You can literally hear her walk over to the cage bring the rat over then the little rat's like
Okay, I don't know what noises rats make but I was like
um
and it's like
They couldn't even say that the ear licking was wrong or when she was literally chomping on the ears
But then the rat the rat no get over here. I'm gonna have that
Um, absolutely no, haven't it
Um
Well done youtube keeping kids safe from rats sniffing the mic ASMR. Honestly. She posted the moment
Yeah, like the timestamp was messed up like the timestamp for my booty clap
No, sorry my round of applause ASMR audio
Em was me breathing in the mic like in the ear. Um
Strony the joke her rats came on the mic. What the rest?
I never uploaded big clap ASMR. You can't prove it. That was clear. No, the truth hasn't come out. Put it back inside right now
um, that was
ASMR clapping with my hands ASMR with my hands. Let's see
That's my hands. That was me spanking my back
um
But yes, um, I finally put up the schedule for this week as well
And I know I should probably be using a background right now and background music
But you just have my raw vocals
And it's a very short stream today. I do apologize
And clearly the claps are from jumping jacks. Honestly
Do you do jumping jacks on the D?
Anyway, um
Clap them with our hands without our hands. Exactly. You have some powerful hands looking forward to the celebration stream
The the psych the psychoping one. I'm excited for it too. I just hope I can set up the camera a bit better
But unfortunately I'm like really limited in the angles
I can like do stuff without like the risk of the the camera dropping because I'm going to be honest. Um
I'm cutting my hair. Um in the in the
In the microphone soon for sound effects. Um because I need more hair cutting ASMR sound effects
I'm going to come out of that recording booth looking like a fucking turnip. I'm not even kidding
Um, don't drop us. I have to be somewhat of a booty expert. Oh, yeah
Um, show us some big hands to make this sound. I literally I should play basketball
I have big enemy hands. Um
But yeah
Um
Also, we reached 20,000 subscribers. I don't know that's kind of base
Kind of base. So thank you everyone who's like like subscribed hung out lurked in the shadows
Um, that's incredibly kind of you. Um, the reward and quotation marks or the celebrate
celebrate your story stream is
um one hour of
Workout on ring fit ASMR and then I will take the microphone into the shower with me
um
Uh
And we'll have a shower together as well
But it's somehow going to be ASMR, but I need to turn I'll definitely test out the microphone and stuff this time because the bathtub
I'm so upset the bathtub thing. I'm going to die again. No one hour
Of ring fit basically. I mean do like what 45 minutes and bring you into the shower and then
No pheromone max please. No, I need to do this shower gonna heart rate one or yeah, I'll do the heart rate one
um
Make sure it's not extremely difficult. Yes, I will lower the the settings or whatever, but yes, we're going to do
That where we did a little shower and stuff. I don't know if acce is gonna keep yapping
um
If acce keeps yapping I might actually redirect entire and then I'll get ready for my
Does it feel like
Are
I'm gonna end this stream. Oh fuck. I'm gonna see you again tomorrow
At the same time
I'm gonna redirect into acce. She's yapping a bit. Uh, anyway, I'm ending stream
Little sleepy acce. Okay. Okay. Okay. I'll wrap it up. Wrap it up
Um, I'll see if there's someone else on that can redirect into because I don't think she
Sheepsters may be
strumming later
Um, I do have a membership hercules watch long. I'm gonna get a little sued in the couple
Um
Wait what
She be streams in four hours. Oh, there's no way I'm sending right. Okay. I'll just I'll redirect into someone. That's why
that ain't me
um
Nanny is streaming. I'll uh redirect into nanny because she was nice to me as soon as nanny was nice to me. I'm like, oh my god
I love you. Thanks for being nice to me
um
She hasn't waited 4.7 hours is a diabolical way, so yeah
But uh redirected to nanny. Oh my god. Did you hear the news uh about that gen 2 hololiver reason?
Oh my god. She had such a fantastic run
Anyway, sorry. That was just general
That was just general. Um
Take care. Um, what I'm going to do is I'm going to redirect into nanny. Okay. Watch me whip. Watch me
Um, and then I am going to
Make a cup of tea and get some food and then for those of you who are members
We'll do a members watch along
Um, again, I do apologize for the different start of time
I wasn't gonna make icy randomly wait 2 extra hours just to stream on mad time
So I'd rather make it as easy as possible for the girls to like so then we can be like, yep
Well collab and the girls are also planning collabs among each other
um
But yes, um a lot of collabs are coming
For me anyway, I'm trying to be a bit more social. Um
I'm a bit I'm a bit of a I get like so zoomed in on work that I don't have time to
kind of
You know burst out the bubble, but I my goal is
Hopefully by the end of this month. I'll have streamed at least with everyone in violour and then at least with a couple of other folk as well
I have another collab that I might be able to say up
If the girls want me
I don't know
You mean hunky leaves
Still a fun stream. I don't really enjoy. I don't know. I got I got a serotonin boost when I figured that out instantly
What I needed to do
But it was really annoying just standing about being like what an error that we need to do like it's not obvious
Um, but yes, I I'm gonna go offline. I will see you tomorrow. Um, and if I don't see you through the week
I'll see you through the window or something like that that used to be a burst then I can't remember
Um
Tomorrow we're doing
Answering questions. You are too afraid to ask. Oh my god. I was delirious when I put up all these rooms by the way
Everything was spelled horrifically wrong. Like I spelt my community posts wrong
I spelt I was spelling everything wrong. I was delirious when I put up all these weight rooms
So I I do apologize if you're like, uh, why is everything so messed up?
And because I'm dumb
Um, what kind of questions do you anticipate? So I oh, yeah, we also have the 15k celebrations. I can later on
Um, what's different than usual honestly though, but like something I messed up
It was in the community post and I put the wrong like can is it connective or whatever the word is
and it was like
Uh, I was like this week is a smaller length of streams, but that doesn't take away from how much fun
I have spending every last moment from you and I was like from you
It's with you
And I was like, oh my god, the reflosers are gonna throw up if they read that so I had to change it really quickly
I'm like, oh my god, they're gonna project a vomit if it makes it sound like I'm like trying to be away from them
What the fuck what the fuck
All right. No, I do like you. That's my stream every single day
I'll the only time I get pieces when I'm with you
Um, she hates I know I'm done. I'm just really dumb and small-brained
Um, but yes tomorrow is a zatsu type stream
I'm I'm slowly testing zatsu in terms of having like a mission objective and then doing it
So I'm gonna answer questions like how are bridges built because you're obviously too afraid to ask
You only like it when we give you money stop. I will literally cry people genuinely think that
Um, I was gonna answer questions like oh, how are bridges built or like why do onions make humans cry?
Like they also make cats cry like mammals and that so like let's take a look into it
I was gonna do like giffy questions like that where it's like, oh, that's how you get like
I only realized that you know the little
Water on the side of the street
I always say this because it's so mind-blowing to me
I used to be like, oh, there's like loads of random water puddles on the side of the street
Yeah, that isn't water. It's dog piss like it never occurred to me that that's dog pee
Um, for some reason. I just thought it randomly rained or something leaked
Like from a pipe or something on the side like I on the pavement. I don't know why it took me years to figure that out
I like it doesn't taste like I didn't taste
Um, it's something in the root part if you don't cut it you don't have any tears
See, well, we're gonna discover it tomorrow
But if you guys have any giffy questions you want to ask in marshmallow, I'm all ears. I will happily answer. I'm all ears
Um, real life streamer rain. Hi mommy. I'm sorry. No, don't be sorry. As I said, this was an awkward stream time
Um, I am gonna get prepared for the member stream. Um, I don't know how many
Music so many songs are recognized, but
Um, yeah nice kind of easy week
Nice general week on me. Um, the veal or clipping program is getting announced today. I did the work yesterday
Now I need the website to be updated because I don't handle that stuff. That's management that deals with that. Um
So once the website's updated the
Twitter the veal or twitter
will have
a
Advertising post and then I'll get the girls to repeat it. Then we'll see what people's reactions are
I mean, I think it's fair if you get one viral clip you get
210 bucks from it. So I think it's yeah, but that's just me
I'm trying to be as fair as possible and I'm trying to, you know, get garr gather in Torre
How about advice questions? I need some advice. I'll change my life
I'm not sure I have it every single song gonna be bombarded with questions. How cute and lovely you are
Oh my god, my marshmallows got so inkable yesterday. I was like, what happened? Why did we both get so
You know
Um, is lava a solid or a liquid?
Oh, I like that question. I would say it's a solid
But maybe it is a liquid
I don't know
Well, did you know but the clip the clips the um
One question doesn't clap absolutely any day of the week. I do it right now, but
It's an exposed me
So I can't do it right now
Um, gotta give my me some material for stress relief. Honestly though, I think I'll probably I'm not gonna lie
There's probably gonna be an all audio after I post the photos because if you guys send me audios of you
I'm gonna go feral. I'm gonna be
Nam a liquid I say I would say a liquid. I it does flow like a liquid
I suppose lava liquid, but magma solid. Yeah
Yeah
Paying the I'm preparing the material as we speak honestly the golem side take over her
If I can drink it it's liquid
I hope you're not drinking liquid in lava in your free time getting ready
Bro, I'm so excited to do it. I'm so excited to be such a fucking tease. I love being a little tease
I don't know why I find it so satisfying
I find it
There's something that activates all my neurons of like, yeah, you can't stop yourself from inking into this
Oh, I've already got the oil ready for the picture
Got my little thigh
Anyway
I just I just
Maybe
Okay, I'm gonna love you. I leave you and I'll see. Oh, good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. By the way
I couldn't see it
um
But yes, um, I will give me five minutes and I'll set up the membership stream and if you are not a member
Please don't worry
And your support is more than enough even if you're lurking in the shadows leaving a like all that jazz
Don't worry about it. As I said, I stream every single day
Um, and I ensure that I stream a public stream every single day and just for you know
Don't don't feel bad if you can't give me the money. You don't need to give me the money
Okay
Love you moment. Love you
If you're a member
Wow
Um, I give you all the kisses right give me five minutes and I'll set up my little movie stream
Thank you so much for watching the collab with acycle. Please don't be afraid to check out acy. She is adorable
She's a goofy goober. Um
Her link is always in my description as is all my gen mates if you ever find yourself being like, huh, I'm bored of strongy goods
Because I got five more girls for you and if you're sick of those five girls good
Because we got six more in the print in the tummy and like a month's time
All right, you guys are going out the donut thorn isn't even a thing for Jen to um
But yes, thank you so so much. I give you a big kiss on the mouth
um
And I'll see you tomorrow. Okay, and I see you in five minutes of your member. Okay. Bye. Bye kisses
Bye bye